present trump this morning turns away
from russia to focus on the environment
and jobs
he will sign an executive order erasing
many of former president obama's climate
change regulations Margaret Brennan is
at the White House with the new rules
for power plant and coal mining Margaret
good morning
good morning well the White House is
trying to shift back focus to campaign
promises it can keep and while he's
previously called climate change a hoax
now White House officials say President
Trump believes it
despite his change of heart today he'll
repeal Obama era regulations to limited
candidate Donald Trump often called
climate change of fake concept we're
going to cancel the Paris climate
agreement and promised to scrap the
Obama era climate change agreement to
limit greenhouse gas emissions in more
than a hundred countries mr. Trump may
stick with the global deal but has
decided to issue an executive order
reducing regulations on America's energy
industry another campaign promise the
regulation industry is one business I
will absolutely put to an end day one he
will suspend revise or rescind the clean
power plan rule aimed at reducing carbon
emissions ask the Interior Department to
lift a moratorium on the sale of new
coal leases on federal land and scrap a
limit on greenhouse gas emissions for
construction of new power plants we can
be both Pro jobs and Pearl environment
the EPA Administrator Scott Pruett says
those Obama era regulations cost jobs
the executive order is going to address
the past administration's effort to kill
jobs across this country through the
clean power plan but at a time of low
energy prices some jobs may not return
and mr. Trump's actions will certainly
reignite the debate over whether climate
change is man-made this is a an action
plan for destroying the climate David
donnager of the National Resources
Defense Council we're leaving a very bad
future for our kids rising sea levels
terrible storms scorching droughts more
air pollution
it's really a bad place you don't want
to go there
and later today President Trump will
roll back those regulations a campaign
promise that won him support in coal
mining industrial states like West
Virginia and Pennsylvania